bueno y le estamos dando una repasada
general a todas estas cosas que estamos
suponiendo constantes o que no cambian
cuando nosotros hablamos acerca de la
curva de la demanda y ahora haremos una
pequeña lista acerca de las que faltan
pero antes de hacer todas las que faltan
mejor déjenme hablarles acerca de lo que
les voy a hablar así que las cosas que
mantienen esto constante y lo voy a
escribir aquí déjenme ponerlo las cosas
que mantienen esto constante mantienen
constante es decir que la curva de la
demanda no se mueva ni a la derecha en
la izquierda número uno es el precio de
los bienes relacionados precio de los
bienes relacionados la segunda cosa que
dijimos que mantenía esto constante era
el precio esperado en un futuro acerca
de nuestro producto y ahora déjenme
listar un par más de estos los cuales
nos van a ayudar a tener más intuición y
tal vez en los siguientes vídeos lo
explique con mucha más calma o explica
unos casos especiales sobre estas cosas
que mantienen constante la curva de la
demanda así que una tercera cosa que
mantiene constante la curva de la
demanda son los ingresos y esto es
completamente intuitivo qué es lo que va
a pasar si el link
de cada una de las personas aumenta es
decir a todos los pagan mejor que es lo
que va a suceder pues por lo tanto de
manera repentina ya tenemos todos más
ingresos y entonces tenemos más dinero
para gastar en este caso para gastar en
libros electrónicos y por lo tanto en
cada uno de los puntos de nuestra curva
de la demanda va a aumentar la cantidad
de demanda y una vez más estamos
hablando de que la curva es la demanda
se va a desplazar hacia la derecha y
entonces el ingreso se va hacia arriba y
lo que quiere decir es que la demanda
aumenta y bueno no está de más recordar
de que toda la curva de la demanda es la
que se va a ir hacia la derecha para
cualquier precio de todos estos puntos
de la curva de la demanda la cantidad de
demanda va a aumentar y por lo tanto
recuerda que toda esta tabla de la
demanda también va a cambiar y bueno
también suena muy lógico que cuando los
ingresos disminuyen entonces la demanda
va a disminuir pero eso sí en los
siguientes vídeos vamos a hablar que no
siempre este es el caso esto solamente
es cierto que nosotros tenemos bienes
normal
bueno otro más que no cambia la curva de
la demanda y que también es muy
intuitivo es la población y una vez más
si la población sube entonces tiene
sentido hablar de que para cualquier
precio dado la cantidad de demanda va a
aumentar o dicho de otra manera la
demanda va a aumentar y bueno ahora
imagínate que la población se vaya hacia
abajo por lo tanto qué es lo que va a
suceder pues la demanda va a disminuir
toda esta curva entera se va a desplazar
hacia la izquierda y la última va a ser
las preferencias es decir estamos
diciendo que si las preferencias de la
gente no cambia pues nos mantenemos
constantes en nuestra curva y si las
preferencias cambian pues por lo tanto
la curva de la demanda va a cambiar así
que por ejemplo si hablamos de libros
electrónicos imagínate que el autor va a
un programa de televisión y en un
programa de televisión se le ocurre
decir que este es el mejor libro que ha
escrito en toda la historia por lo tanto
las preferencias van a aumentar y esto
va a ser que la demanda aumente también
para cualquier precio que esté en estos
puntos no va a importar la cantidad de
demanda va a aumentar y bueno también en
otro caso si las preferencias disminuyen
supongamos que ese
el programa de televisión critica al
autor y dice que éste es el peor libro
que ha leído en todo el año pues
entonces lo que va a pasar es que la
curva de la demanda se va a tirar hacia
la izquierda es decir la cantidad de la
demanda va a disminuir y por lo tanto la
demanda también va a disminuir